let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
let me pull up our news headlines if i
can find them here they are
okay of course you know the big news i'm
told supposedly is president donald
trump
telling bob woodward in march that he
wants to play down the coronavirus
um this is all going to appear in
woodward's forthcoming book rage
about the trump administration i wonder
if it's going to have a positive or
negative spin i don't know it's hard to
tell you can never tell who knows
impossible to predict
um this conversation between charlotte
woodward is on tape
you probably heard the tape by now but
if not here it is again
it goes through air bob that's always
tougher than the touch you know the
touch you don't have to touch things
right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's uh passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
very delicate one
uh it's also more deadly than your you
know
your even your strenuous flues you know
people don't realize we lose twenty five
thousand thirty thousand people a year
here
who would ever think that right i know
that that's pretty amazing
and then i say well is that the same
thing for
this is more deadly this is five per
you know this is five percent versus one
percent and less than one percent
you know so this is deadly stuff so
what is going on give me an a moment of
talking to somebody
going through this with faushi or
somebody
who kind of uh it caused a
pivot in your mind because it's clear
just from
what's in on the public record that you
went through
a pivot on this to oh my god the gravity
is uh almost inexplicable
and unexplainable well i think bob
really to be honest with you sure i want
you to i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down
yes because i don't want to create a
panic okay there you go and
uh he also said trump said at other
times early in february that the virus
is deadly stuff
and worse than the flu and the claim
from trump's critics is that these
private statements contradict what he
said publicly
and show that he lied to the public
there's a lot more
in these interviews he did 18 interviews
with woodward
18 many of them apparently recorded 18
interviews
here's what i'll say about this first of
all he did say in those comments just
played
that he was he was he was playing it
down quote unquote in order to prevent
the public from panicking
now i don't think preventing a panic is
a good reason for a public official to
lie
if you're going to accept that excuse
from the government for lying
then you can't ever criticize the
government for lying because that's
always
the excuse for lying from the government
but on the other hand i don't think that
trump actually was lying necessarily i
think that
what you heard there was more a
reflection of
trump's limited vocabulary than anything
else he said play it down but in the
context it seemed like he really meant
to say something like
allay fears or something like that that
probably would have
caught his meaning a little bit uh
better i think
and besides his public comments were
also all over the place so if his
private comments were all over the place
and his public comments are all over the
place
there are a lot of criticisms you can
make towards him about that but i don't
think you can accuse him of deception or
conspiracy or a cover-up or something
like that
it sounds like the guy was sort of
flailing which is certainly the
impression he gave publicly
as well as privately um so i think all
in all this is not a huge
it's not the huge scandal the left wants
it to be it doesn't reflect well on
trump either but it's not a breathtaking
scandal
which is of course what they what they
are hoping for now that said
my real issue here is that trump decided
to do
18 recorded interviews
with a guy who was writing an expose
about him which
would come out before the election um
that is
inexcusably stupid and it shows
what i've always said which is that
trump is not media savvy
at all he gets credit for he's a he's a
master at media manipulation no
he just does and says stuff randomly
and the media is so incompetent that it
often works out in trump's favor
but a media savvy president would not do
recorded interviews
18 times with a guy who is clearly
against you and wants to write a hit
piece on you
if trump actually thought there was any
chance that bob woodward would write a
positive book about him
then that's the dumbest thing of all um
there is just no scenario where that
works in your favor
the best you can hope for i know that
the people defending trump are saying
this isn't going to hurt him okay well
that's the best you can hope for you sit
down for 18 recorded interviews with bob
woodward
best possible outcome is that it's it's
neutral it doesn't hurt you
in which case it was a waste of time
worst outcome is that it does hurt you
there is no universe at all in which it
helps you
in which prattling to bob woodward 18
times
uh with recordings somehow works in your
favor it just it just
it's not going to so there's no reason
to do it
uh why did trump do it then well because
trump is incapable of saying no to
someone who wants to give him attention
you know it's it really is that simple
and that's one of his
great weaknesses uh i think okay
number two from the daily wire it says
attorney general william barr announced
wednesday that operation legend a
department
of justice program designed to
supplement major city to police
departments with federal agents and
resources amid an unprecedented national
crime wave
has cut the chicago murder rate roughly
in half
since launch and has reversed a surge of
violence that was leaving dozens killed
it says looking for the actual numbers
here about
chicago the results of those actions
speak for themselves over the past five
weeks of operation legend in chicago
murders dropped by 50
over the previous five weeks august
ultimately saw a 45
decrease in murders compared to july at
a 35
decrease compared to june okay
so if i'm interpreting the data here
correctly it would seem that the
takeaway
is that enforcing the law helps reduce
crime yes when when you allow criminals
to
commit crime without consequence you get
more crime
when you impose a consequence you get
less crime there would seem to be a
cause and effect
relationship here possibly and this is
why i've been saying for a long time
that that all of this talk about
criminal justice reform
is focused on reforming in exactly the
wrong way
there is not a crisis in our country of
innocent people being sent to jail
or criminals being given sentences that
are too harsh that's not
now that kind of thing does happen on
occasion but that's not the systemic
issue the systemic issue is that
violent dangerous people are filtered
quickly through the system
and then sent back out onto the streets
that's the systemic problem
the systemic issue is that many people
many of the people out in the street
committing crime are known
to the system to be criminals and to be
dangerous
and yet they're allowed to remain free
great example of this okay
just from this week as well in new york
a guy named daniel biggs
you can see the video here he rode his
bike passed a six-year-old woman
punched her in the head and knocked her
to the ground
and and just kept on riding now
fortunately a bunch of firefighters saw
this happen and were able to chase him
down and apprehend him which is good
but biggs is 53 years old apparently
has 18 prior arrests for robbery assault
and other crimes
now he's out randomly assaulting women
who are just walking down the street
this is a man with nothing to offer a
society
um just violence and crime that's all
he's got to offer
it's all he's got to give uh the re
there is just no reason
to have him out on the street there's no
reforming
somebody like this someone who's been a
scumbag their entire life
and now at the age of 53 is still out
randomly assaulting people just for fun
there's no reforming there's no real
hope
that one day this will be a productive
member of society
this is someone who you throw into a
cage and you keep them there
forever okay you say to that person
you're done you've had your chance
you've had many chances
you clearly don't want to behave like a
human being you're not interested in
that
so this is what you get we're going to
throw you in a cage
um but what happened to biggs though
well he was charged a few days later and
released on bail
they released him 18 arrests he's doing
that they release him out on bail what
do you think
is biggs going to show up diligently for
his court appearance
is he going to wear a nice suit come to
the court on the day that's
assigned and you know face his the
consequences like a man
no of course not so
this is the way it works guys like this
filter through the system
and they end up back on the street
commit more crimes the system is way way
way too lenient not too harsh and that's
where the reform should be focused so
it's good that um
at least on the federal level we're
starting to see some of that okay a man
named safwan
chowdhury posted video yesterday that he
says shows him and his family being
kicked off a west jet flight
in fact the whole flight was was
canceled as a matter of fact because his
19 month old child
was not wearing a mask you can't see or
hear much in the video but i'll play it
for you anyway here it is
this is
[Music]
right
[Music]
now westjet in defense of itself says
that um no the problem was not the 19
month old it was the
uh three-year-old daughter was not
wearing a mask so they canceled the
flight because of that chowdhury
disputes that claim and so there's a he
said he said thing going on
uh here's how here's how it shakes out
as far as i can tell
number one expecting a baby a 19 month
old to wear a mask
is madness and dangerous babies can
suffocate very easily
um you don't you don't put any kind of
fabric
or anything around the face of a baby
period any business that requires that
should be sued
any parent who complies with that is
stupid and gutless beyond words
absolutely you don't put a mask on a
baby you lunatics
but what if it was just the
three-year-old that was the issue well
guess what still stupid
just as stupid many three-year-olds
aren't going to
cooperate with having a mask on and
shouldn't be required to
and it doesn't seem very healthy to me
to have a three-year-old who's panicking
because they don't understand why they
have to have the sting on their face
restricting their breathing
and now they're you know they're trying
to breathe hard they're panicking
they're screaming they got the mask on
no i have a three-year-old uh myself
he's not gonna wear a mask for any long
period of time
he'll put one on for like 45 seconds
mainly just because he sees everyone
else doing it
but then it's going to come off and i'm
not going to force him to wear it i've
said i've said many times that as far as
i'm concerned if a business wants me to
wear a mask i will respect their
property
rights and comply with that even though
i don't like it
but no you're not going to force me to
put a mask on my three-year-old it's
just not going to happen
but here's the thing that really gets to
me about this
going back to that video okay you heard
the child crying
obviously scared confused so
when you think about that requiring
little kids to put masks on
or you know the latest now they're gonna
be canceling trick-or-treat
uh in i think chicago said they're
probably gonna cancel it
even though you're outside the kids are
already wearing masks and costumes so
there's no reason to do it but they're
gonna do it anyway
um or any of the other millions of
examples of the way the ways that kids
have been affected by this
what gets me is that none of this is
about protecting the kids
themselves okay this is not some sort of
misguided but well-meaning attempt to
protect children
i personally have a lot of sympathy for
misguided but well-meaning attempts to
protect children
i sympathize with that because i get it
you know i
i understand as a father i understand
how sometimes you could go a little
overboard in your zealousness to protect
children
i can certainly be guilty of that
sometimes i mean you should see the way
that i cut up food for my three-year-old
it's as if he's an infant cut it up with
these little tiny like microscopic bits
because i'm terrified that it'll choke
and it's it's way overboard
my wife makes fun of me but uh i i can't
help it it's a it's my greatest fear as
a kid choking
so i go way overboard sometimes too to
protect them
uh in certain areas but that's not what
this is about with the coronavirus
no this is about selfish and scared
adults trying to protect
themselves from the kids
insisting that a baby wear a mask and
i'm counting a three-year-old as a baby
in this in this context
insisting that a baby wear a mask no
matter how scared and confused and
terrified he is
or how unhealthy it is for him in order
so that you
can be protected from him is the height
of cowardice and selfishness
i mean even even leaving aside the fact
that
the kid's not going to spread
chronovirus to you kids
this has been established many times
over kids are very unlikely to contract
it and spread it
but even aside from that we're doing all
of this
to kids to protect ourselves because
we're afraid
this is this these aren't things we're
doing for them
it's things we're forcing them to do for
us which is exactly backwards
number four i cancelled gender reveal
parties on the show earlier this week
you may remember the daily show with
trevor noah is behind the times they
came in and canceled them too
but frankly i thought my cancellation
was uh way better
than this watch but guys this has to
stop
right or at least if you insist on a
gender reveal you should do something
that helps the situation
the water's pink it's a girl and aside
from all the damage it can cause
celebrating a baby's genitalia is
starting to feel very
outdated like given everything we're
learning about gender
gender reveal parties should only happen
when the child is old enough to know
their actual gender
and to pitch in some cash for the fire
damage
and honestly i don't even know why we
need gender reveal parties
you know what we do need though race
reveal parties
trevor noah's really has the charisma
and comedic chops of like a pillow case
filled with wet sand um and
i've never heard the guy tell a funny
joke have you i've never
i if anyone is aware of a funny trevor
noah
moment from any point in his career
pre-daily show or during the dale show
let me know because i've never
i i've never seen it and i've looked and
the thing what the thing is
there was a time long ago when the daily
show might have done that exact same
segment with the same lines and
everything
and it would have been funny because the
bit at the end about choosing gender
would have been satirical it would have
been a joke
10 years ago that bit would have been
satire
and today it is something that is
delivered in earnestness
and sincerity um by the way trevor
you say uh everything we've learned
about gender is
what what is that exactly what have we
learned what exactly have we learned
scientifically
proving that gender can be chosen rather
than uh
rather than it being something you're
born with i'd really like to know you
said we've learned okay we've learned a
lot
everything we've learned give me like
one thing we've learned
that justifies what you just said well
you can't
he can't they never can hey you uh yeah
you you're right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now
do it do it right now i thank you for
your compliance
it's somewhat appreciated